-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's great to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
The White House is reportedly
considering major changes
for its communications team.
For example,
they're going to get one.
[ Laughter ]
The National Archives yesterday
asked the Secret Service
to provide information
about the deletion
of agents' text messages
pertaining
to the Capitol attack.
Who's laughing now...
said the one agent
with an Android
who wasn't allowed
in the group chat.
[ Laughter ]
Britain's Prince William
and Duchess Kate Middleton
announced today
that they will travel to Boston
later this year.
This news was first reported
by Paul Revere.
[ Laughter ]
Former New York mayor
Bill de Blasio
announced yesterday he's ending
his congressional campaign,
and I'm guessing this is
not how Bill de Blasio
wanted everyone to learn
he had a congressional campaign.
[ Laughter ]
Today was
National Pennsylvania Day.
"Where the hell is that?"
asked Dr. Oz.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new list, Vermont
is the best state to live in.
Well, no wonder.
He always looks so happy.
[ Laughter ]
Netflix reported yesterday
that it lost nearly
1 million subscribers
in the last three months.
Well, Netflix, I think you
finally have your answer.
[ Laughter ]
Two governing bodies
of quidditch have announced
that they will change the name
of the sport to quadball
in an effort to distance
themselves from J.K. Rowling.
Said bullies, "Fine,
let's go beat up
the quadball players, then!"
[ Light laughter ]
When asked about his song
"American Pie"
in a new documentary,
singer Don McLean
said the jester mentioned in
the lyrics is not James Dean.
He also said, "Please,
please don't sing that song
at karaoke."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
after a man recently fell
and injured himself
at Lake Tahoe,
his border collie ran 200 yards
through the remote area
of the forest
to lead rescue crews
to his owner,
while his French bulldog ran
six feet and immediately died.
And that --
You end on an up.
You end the monologue on an up.
That was the monologue,
everybody!